how's it go Maurice how you know how you
[ __ ] know when - climbing welcome back
to another episode of The Walking Dead
last episode we met up cousin Jarrett's
concert October 13th 1998 I hope it's
some really thick German rape music [ __ ]
ya some kinky rabies me of school uh-huh
Paulie ol Claim she's never going to
school again because she had a pen that
she threw in a main space remind me to
never be a rapper what are you guys
doing here glad we could use some help
here Sarah you take this and string them
up over there you know Kenny before it
must be incredible to see him again when
I met him
well he's so different now but you must
be so glad so how do you meet Kenny yeah
I wanna know
I found him holed up in an old
restaurant if you can believe it I'll
believe it up you should have seen his
beard then perfect now we just need the
chopper we always had an angel on top of
our tree my family didn't celebrate
Christmas but I still loved the
decorations so it's my job to find the
tree topper deburr celebrate Christmas
is crazy I can't be sure it's been a
week man we gotta be out of the woods we
can't be sure they might be tracking us
track him what do you think they are
ninjas Clem Luke said you saw some
people in the valley people way down
there how she's got binoculars genius
yeah yeah it's a lie did you see
Clementine I saw light which way did
they go
back into the woods we cannot take any
chances
we leave at dawn but we're safe here for
tonight right
Clementine you talk to that man Walter
right what did he say
you didn't tell him anything about us
did you we have to be careful he
mentioned someone else someone else who
his friend his name is Matthew look I
don't care what that man said we're
staying here tonight
just talk to the rest of them they trust
you
see what you can find out I'm gonna go
find Luke there's a I don't feel so good
then what's wrong I just need something
to drink
you got it I'll be right back there's so
much wrong going on right now so Matthew
is probably the guy that we shot and it
looks like she's about to get mine and
we're about it again what do you want hi
are you okay
just got a little dizzy yeah I can't
even take care of myself how am I
supposed to raise a child how can anyone
now
everything so [ __ ] up I think it's
possible how do you know well I'm still
here
that faith I know it's gonna be hard but
at the same time
I already feel a little less because I
know that no matter what happens I'll
get to meet someone new
hopefully not exactly want to listen
that food smells good gross no thanks
it's okay I'm gonna get you something
soon okay Karen I I guess I'll do it
just to make her happy I I don't like
this stuff it's weird
so he's gonna be a runner hey chin up
there it's gonna be okay it's not his
Artie who is it that however finds out
he'll kill me what the [ __ ] to do he's
[ __ ] leave I'm asking a little girl
for device yeah what but I guess
nothing's weird anymore he won't kill
you there's my man you all right baby
I'm fine you big dope just need to get
some food in you thanks for staying with
her Clem can you ask that Walter dad
when we gonna eat I love you silly bear
I hate it when you called me that I know
but I mean it I love you too here's some
rest now know why teleporting he's
teleporting he's a teleport I prefer
this star but it's stupid to look girl
was a stupid angel so I guess we go over
this stupid angel
he deserves to know man you can't raise
a child lighter than yours without
knowing it that's [ __ ] [ __ ]
she looks so cool beautiful I used to
love this time of year angels only cool
you know
now that your friends are here this
place is starting to feel like a real
home Matthew and Walter are amazing
people
honestly it's dangerous to be this kind
but they can't help it wait until you
meet Matthew he's a real character the
first time he met me he called me Rita
so I call him Matty now what does
Matthew look like oh he's a handsome man
little shorter than Walter he should be
back soon
is that it Clem I wanted to ask you does
Kenny seem different to you I didn't
know him before and well I'm curious
good days bad days like everyone else
but lately I get the feeling he's
struggling he does seem different than I
remember in what way I'm not sure well
you three have been busy Kenny isn't it
great I got it on I think I can manage
Ken I said I got it
what yeah you see always has to play the
gentleman but I'll tell you when I met
him he couldn't lift a fly well everyone
dinner is served
come on let's see so I think they're
changing that little girl because that
why else would they care so much about
getting the group you know
you probably think is his daughter and
that's why a hide Center makes her not
go out it's not okay man yeah just I
wish I'd pulled that trigger just try to
forget about it
right of your claim now gosh are they
gonna make me pick now that's the way to
awkward I can't do this
Oh No look at him you look so alone and
he has to sit with neck and I mean neck
is such an idiot
whoo I can't let him stay alone with
neck lane but can it's been so long and
that can just look like me so I guess
it'll be a good substitute I feel like I
should say with my group for now because
I feel like shit's about to come break
down soon sorry I can I didn't mean to
make you side
we'll talk later Ken don't worry about
it so what's the deal with your friend
here yes we were just talking about this
Kenny what do you make of him Flynn yeah
trust them I trust him with your life
yeah I think so
Walter was telling me his family died
that's horrible
shut up thing like that can hit a guy
pretty hard he lost his whole family
wife and kid dad he lost it a little
after that lost it happened well he
drinks oh well we all do
everyone in this show does he's Kenny
gonna come over yes awesome
see ya it was funny there hey hope you
like the food
oh it's it's great thank you
peaches and beans great for nutrition
not too great on the way out though I
tell you so it's Luke and Nick Luke and
Nick you guys sure do look like a match
what's that supposed to mean I'm just
saying you look like good friends that's
all so what was your plan here hold out
for the winner actually we were thinking
of moving on somewhere up north you ever
heard of a place called Wellington yeah
Wellington Chris hell was that a place
yeah Krista and I were going there
supposed to be a big camp up near
Michigan Michigan you got a hearing
problem kid
yeah Michigan think about it fresh water
lots of land and cold ass winters so the
walkers gets lost sounds like [ __ ]
listen Vanilla Ice I don't know what
your deal is but you're more than
welcome to take off in the morning just
fine by me what's the deal with these
guys clang [ __ ] you buddy
it's fine hey don't please don't fight
yeah
gentlemen please there's no need for
this now look we've all had a long day
please eat ask me that can duck Duck
Duck
leave him alone hey Clementine would you
lend me a hand outside for a moment he's
still really scarred from what happened
after all he didn't really recover or
whatever even though he made a new
girlfriend what I am I'm sorry about
that I'm sorry but I used a teacher and
I remember what it's like to be caught
in the middle of two clicks I suspect
they'll find common ground soon enough
it may take a little time but that's
just how these things work everything
will be fine
okay listen relationships are like any
machine you don't throw them out when
they break down you get your hands dirty
and you grease the wheels what do you
say will you help me work on them we're
gonna leave in the morning no no you got
to stay we have to keep moving
Clementine in this world you don't have
to do anything they say the world is
over but I'll tell you a secret
it's not
people are more political now than they
ever were before in the end we can't
change the world all we can do is
continue to learn from each other to
empathize and use our heads all war is a
symptom of man's failures of thinking
animal steinbeck have you read him well
we have plenty of time to catch you up
on your reading my partner Matthew is
amassing quite the literature collection
I think you'll like them in any case the
point is as long as we have our wits
about us we can always make the right
choice
right
what's the matter Clementine is there
something you want to tell me I think we
should tell them
you can talk to me Glenn there's almost
nothing you could tell me that would
surprise me I can promise you that I'm
just worried about the people chasing us
you're safe now
don't worry Matthew will be back soon
and everything will be fine hey kids
what are you two talking about they're
gonna spill the pizza Oh
politics the hell not being from Florida
I would imagine you know all about
politics Kenny man I know one advantage
of living in the apocalypse is not
dealing with that [ __ ] no more hmm I was
just gonna check the windows around back
before this storm hits give us a hand
sure
[Music]
No who's that miss oh it seems from 400
days what's her name uh please have any
food are you okay
I saw the house and I have a family
we're starving we live down there of
course
why don't you come in Miss Bonnie Bonnie
yeah Walt I don't know you're just gonna
let her in like that it's fine Kenny we
don't know this girl then we'll have to
get to know her right Clem
Walt how much damage can this poor woman
do check her for weapons my Jail thank
you really but that storm will be on us
soon and I gotta get back to my family
I'll bring something out to you then you
don't have to do that no no it's fine
what about your people we've got plenty
you stay put I'll be right back
I don't think they have plenty at all
we're gonna have to talk to me this girl
I have a little girl like you
hmm how old are you sweetie I'm 11
I would have thought older than that
here you are miss this is too much
don't mention it I don't know how to
thank you just help someone else down
the line thank you so much I'll be going
now you stay safe you too
Hey well he's nice I've been planted go
on inside and get to bed Walton I got to
talk for a second that can't be good
it's gonna go I don't know what the hell
is gonna happen though Sam yes freak out
why would I freak out listen okay I
gotta tell you something now [ __ ] that
guy on the bridge was Walter's friend oh
you're not pregnant after something was
off so I asked Sarita about their friend
now they're all worried he's not back
yet what are we gonna do I don't know
I don't think Walter knows yet so we
have to keep this quiet
I mean who knows what the hell he do if
he found out then we should tell him we
should tell him he's gonna ask who did
it and you're gonna tell him it's the
right thing to do
it's right to get Nikhil because that's
what's gonna happen now do you uh you
still have that knife because if it was
Matthews and Walter season he's gonna
put two and two together it's with the
other weapons okay well go get rid of it
now find Walter and run interference oh
and uh keep an eye out for Nick right
here
what's up hmm oh uh there's nothing man
I just wanted it check and see if you're
okay nothing mm-hmm if there's something
going on I want to know I don't want to
tell it I see you just go back to bed
Nick I'm serious
you guys can talk to me I know what you
don't trust me now
fine fine you know what
Last Chance lies [ __ ] chance if you
freak out I'm gonna kill you oh Jesus
come on
god damn hey Nick shut the [ __ ] up I
can't man I can't do not [ __ ] blow it
blow it it's over I have to tell him
Luke
what no UK Nick you cannot do that are
you [ __ ] nuts I got it
I can't live with that on me okay I hear
you
but I mean [ __ ] man do you know what
he's gonna do either way is risky
exactly Jesus eggs that I can't handle
this look what just go do that thing all
right what what what what what what
thing mm-hmm oh yeah we have is a knife
yeah forgot about it dad but it's not
there it's gone don't tell me don't tell
me oh how did that even happen yeah I
thought it was talking to kandi
this is gonna be awkward Walter Walter I
always liked this knife well he's gonna
snap gave it to Matthew and all this
started I know he's dead
who did it was it that the kid what's
his name Nick heard him talking earlier
or something about shooting a man
I could see
I could see it on his face wasn't sure
that but now
it was us you get sometimes I don't know
man maybe in Jesus are you know I don't
feel good
Nick shot him
this is gonna be so so [ __ ] bad
is Nick a good man or is he just like
everyone else see just one of those huh
those [ __ ] that don't give a [ __ ]
about anyone but themselves he is he's a
good guy Walter
he saved my life ah he was always going
out alone
I told him something like this would
happen but he wouldn't listen no mado is
noobest what's going on or you know you
need to tell him tell him what
what happened on the bridge
tell me what you did
just tell me something tell me what
happened
from a distance it looked like anyone I
thought I thought he was gonna shoot my
friends and I
I shot Matthew baby but you hadn't real
fast I didn't I didn't know if I hit him
but I did and I didn't mean to do you
know what you've done to me do you have
any idea I didn't mean to
I'm so sorry I'm so sorry Walter
put the gun now I mean the knife and we
can shave your unibrow they won't be
okay Wow
Wow
well what's going on
poor guy
the storms got it spinning out of
control that sounds gonna draw walkers
we got to shut it down now they help me
carry the guns guns
I think's a damn dinner bell
it's not that loud okay it is
he'll say dammit
transformer musta come gotta check it I
could use a hand I'll go with you no
it's too dangerous
Christy get this big shut down man
this is so intense me I got a head and a
hip it's over here but if you enjoy
watching breath go ahead and like it
wakes up the sleepy Edgar oh yeah he
just got a new trick so inside an extra
support thank everyone for watching I'll
see I'm sorry about the hangar but I
gotta end it I'm really sorry I gotta go
customers love you
[Music]